let me start by saying congrats on the
series
first two episodes are great thank you
thank you so much
uh i am curious how old do you think
your character
is how old do i think she is
yeah because i i'm wondering about the
tva and how old these characters are
well that's that's an interesting
question because
the tva exists outside of
time and space it's its own world so i i
don't think you can quantify it with
time
i don't think you can quantify them with
time sure i don't think i celebrate
birthdays
did you ask michael or kate like hey how
old is my character were you sort of
just like there's no answer
you know owens character says it best
time moves differently in the in the tva
you can't you can't answer that question
you just can't
go all right i'll leave it alone um what
was it like for you hearing
that uh you might be getting a gig in
the mcu
it was amazing i i i got the
call saying i had been offered a part in
loki
but i hadn't known i was auditioning for
loki so it was quite uh
a shock and then very very exciting
and i was finally um going to be a part
of the marvel universe which just feels
so good and i hadn't i didn't really
know what my character was going to
do at that point but i was like i'm in
either way yeah i would imagine that's
what a lot of at this point the quality
of their of their
uh content is so high that it's sort of
like yeah
i'll do it you know exactly you know
it's going to be good
100 um what surprised you about making
loki that perhaps you weren't expecting
a global pandemic
[Laughter]
yeah that took us by complete surprise
and
yeah i mean that was the biggest
thing i mean i had read
a lot of the scripts and been talked
through the scripts and and
there are the the the the things that
happen in the script that are surprising
and but other than that
like it's it's it's going to work on
a on a set which is as
usual for me and the
the the biggest surprises are what
happens in the script
and the global pandemic no completely
before i run out of time i was a big fan
of lovecraft
uh and i am i am curious uh what's going
on with season two
are you doing it what can you say i
don't know i have no idea what's going
on with season two yet
no idea so you haven't been told
anything
not yet really i was hoping you were
going to be like
they told me to save some dates later
this year
well may you may find out before i do
i completely get okay my last question
for you i would imagine making loki was
amazing
but was there like a day or two that
you'll always remember from the filming
process
there's so much i will remember
conversations
with the cast and getting to know each
other and sharing our stories
and and and and and and just falling in
love with each other a little bit all of
us
it was it was it was amazing and
i'll remember the day that we had to you
know
say stop for go on hiatus i'll remember
that day
um and i'll remember the day that we
actually finished it
like you know because it was nearly a
year
you know and so
yeah i'll remember i don't think i'll
ever forget this job actually i don't
think i'll forget a moment from it
because it's
quite an extraordinary time in my life
it's it has been yeah it's a pleasure to
talk to you today i wish you nothing but
the best
and good luck with the rest of your
speed dating thank you